hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today is my
birthday so this is my birthday stream
I'm 33 years old now and my main camera
stopped working so I that's why the
angles a little bit weird so I switched
to the camera on my secondary display my
my good webcam is at my house I didn't
bring it in the office today
so I'm gonna do my best to try to look
at this camera when I can but you're
probably gonna be seeing a lot of this
side of my face just because of habit of
normally looking here so today I think
we're going to do a little bit of coding
we have a look do a little bit of
question and answer so I'd like to be
done before 3:00 because I have a
meeting at 3:00 and that's Eastern Time
so want to finish this up maybe in 50
minutes that would be good so we'll
probably do about 25 minutes of coding
and then the rest for question and
answer I'm going to assume we'll have a
lot of questions since we normally do if
we don't then I'll just keep on coding
and oh let me give you an update on my
job search so it's been a while
apologies for not streaming as much as I
normally do and you know what I need to
I keep looking over to see the chat I'm
just going to move it over right under
this camera so the hip I can see it and
look at the same time I see a lot of
people saying happy birthday thank you
so much wow that's a lot of happy
birthdays I really appreciate that thank
you so here's what's up with my job
search I've gone on a lot of the
interviews now and I've done a lot of
technical interviews and take home
coding challenges I have received four
job offers so of the four offers I'm
pretty I'm considering three of the four
right now one of the four is a little
bit low so it kind of declined it and so
then basically there's three offers
still running but the the really really
exciting news I mean I'm excited about
all the offers but the news that I
didn't think I'd be able to share is
that I made it to the next round of
interviews with Google so I am i took
the over the phone
technical interview I passed it and now
I'm gonna go in for five in-person
technical interviews at Mountain View at
their headquarters so I'm just I'm so
excited I've been studying a lot now and
I'm gonna keep studying it looks like I
might be out there this Thursday so it's
not for sure yet but I think Thursday
will be the day so that gives me a
couple more days to to get ready and
then there's one other job that I'm
still in the interview process for so I
need to finish actually I didn't think
I'd have enough time I'd kind of give it
up on that because I thought this
interview process is going to take too
long I'm gonna have to get back to these
other companies but I think it's gonna
work out that I might be able to get
through that process so there's
potentially two more companies so maybe
two more offers but I have to get
through the process so I plan on making
a video of that putting it on my youtube
channel the link to my channels in the
description and I'm gonna summarize this
whole process and explain what the
interviews were like and how I make my
final decision so that will come out
after the whole process which is taking
even longer than I thought but and it
definitely in a good way also if you
want updates on my interview process
I've been putting some updates on
Twitter so my Twitter links in the
description as well but I've been doing
a lot of video updates on my Instagram
story so if you're on Instagram and you
want to get those those updates check
out my Instagram I believe I have info
about it in the description of this
video so I have I have all my story
saved on my profile under job
interviews or something like that so you
can kind of catch the back load of
everything okay enough updates I want to
make sure you actually get some coding
and question and answer stuff so if you
have questions about that process let me
know but I will go over it in more depth
at some point so hopefully I'll cover
everything if I see a lot of people are
interested in one certain part maybe
they'll spend more time on that part
okay let me move the time I move the
chat off the window for a second and
then get the code up here and then
switch over oh yeah okay here's the code
you can find a link to this github
repository in the description and you
can also find the link to the live
version of this this site in the
description as well so we have a
basically a demo live version of the
site and right now
first thing I want to do and the first
thing we should always do and we're
starting up a project that we're using
git to track is we want to do a git pull
uh-oh I need my my the power went out
yesterday I think and so my computer
restarted so bear with me one second
here while I get my get my SSH
passphrase in here
okay cool so that worked let's see what
happened we got a bunch of new branches
from greenkeeper which lets us know when
a new package a new version of a package
we using has come out so we got a lot of
updates to do at some point we're not
gonna do the updates right now on the
stream though also if you don't want to
have to keep typing in your SSH password
or key or whatever you can do SSH add
and then paste in your key and then now
you won't need to do it again for as
long as your computer is on alright so
now that that's taken care of
I think okay I mean sync now it looked
like I was out of sync with the video a
little bit apologies I know that's
that's kind of annoying okay so now
we're in sync let's start up our dev
server I've got a double check dev yearn
dev some projects it's set up to be
start and some projects it's dev okay so
we should be ready on localhost
let's start a Pomodoro timer and let's
get localhost 3000 running okay I'm not
gonna start the end rock server right
now which I'd normally do so if you want
to see the site just check it out on the
link in the description I'm just I'm not
gonna start it just because we have a
tight schedule at this point and there
we go we have our rotating pictures now
so this one happens to be the university
president for the Shawn so we've done a
bit on the home page I don't remember if
you all have seen some of these updates
but I've had a few updates here but the
page we're gonna work on today is
admissions let's see what it looks like
now okay not so great right now right
yeah
so I recently found out that the people
in admissions were not happy about how
this page looks and to be honest with
you I can't blame them right this page
doesn't look great
we essentially put all the relevant
admissions information on the front page
and then link directly to the programs
and so although we got all the we did
get all the information and where we
wanted it to be optimal for people to
actually click on we we didn't quite
finish this but the good news is we
already have a test page that makes us
look a lot better so my next step here
is going to be to go to github and check
out the history for that file because I
don't think we made a separate branch
for that which we probably should have I
think we on the master branch changed it
and then reverted it back because it
wasn't quite finished before launch and
it it was almost the same as the
homepage at the time so we made a
decision to revert it back and then work
on it but now things have changed on the
homepage so I think we can just use that
same format make it the admissions page
and it should work great I see some
activity there in the chat I will
definitely get to read your comments and
your questions here as soon as the
Pomodoro timer is up which will be by
minds so far over here okay well I still
got 23 minutes all right so let's go to
Franciscan react and the link to this is
in the description if you want to check
it out and so I want to go to our pages
folder we're using next js' so our pages
folder our actual routes we do have some
custom routes happening here so we're
kind of overriding a lot of the default
behavior of next j/s but just a little
explanation for what this pages folder
does we had admissions
jas okay so for our admissions hey we
still have this page yes okay cool we
don't have to copy and paste anything
now I remember what we did okay let's
check out here's our server Jas photo
let's find admissions let's see
okay so admissions are default we set to
page right and so it's pulling in the
data that's currently in WordPress for
this page but what we can do is set this
to admissions right so this is that
custom routing that's overriding the
default behavior that I was just talking
about so now we're saying if you go to
admissions and it's the default meaning
it's just the bare admissions with no
slash something else at the end in terms
of the URL then we're just gonna have it
render this page admissions okay so
let's save that we see we're running no
daman so it automatically restarts our
server when fire our files change so now
it'll reload and here we go here's our
admissions page so we start out with
this hero section alright we have an
image there we could make this image
change like the homepage image does we
could we could do some different stuff
with it basically so we're but we have
the basic structure here now we have it
set up okay yeah now I see why we didn't
make this live because it while it looks
nicer it's definitely lacking some
information
I remember now this was awhile ago I
remember not having discussions about
what exactly should be on this page and
not really coming to a conclusion okay
that makes sense
all right that makes a lot of sense okay
so here's what we're gonna do
all right we definitely let's take these
out and move them to the bottom of the
homepage and let's move in some more
admission specific data into this
section okay
all right so we'll go back here and
we're going to put on on one side we'll
put the admissions page on the other
side of the screen we'll put the home
page since we're gonna be copy and
pasting quite a bit both of us pages
share the same basic layout so we should
be able to just swap in pieces and
components and they should work if
you're interested in how we we got to
this point in the project this is video
102 of the series so you can check out
the entire project 5 playlist on this
channel on the free code camp Channel
it's quite a lot so I recommend you to
skip around and watch the pieces that
really interest you but you can if
you're interested in a certain part you
know you can definitely you'll get more
info and I'm gonna get rid of some of
these all right here's our homepage I'll
move this over here for now and I'm
gonna get rid of some of these just to
make things a bit easier then here's our
admissions jas great let's get as much
space as we can in here okay so our
homepage is here and I said I'm gonna
scroll we're gonna go all the way to the
bottom and we have this section here
that's just we're using material UI as a
UI framework and we have this built in
great component that lets us do some
nice nice things with the layout so it
within this this grid we have our
our components so actually we have a
larger section here and we're using the
grid inside it but this is our cost and
financial aid section and for right now
I think I'm gonna throw in I'm just
going to throw in some of these profiles
let's make sure I get all of them okay
so this whole grid here is what we need
a little bit too far okay here we go
so let me copy this just completely get
rid of it there we are and move it over
here so this is section yeah let's do it
after this it's the same section or two
years okay let's see how that looks on
the home page here oops and we need to
import our profile cards so we're
getting this little red thing here so up
here let's take let's just copy and
paste this but make it a little faster
but instead of text section and these
are custom components that we built
throughout the course of this project
profile card okay whoops did it
automatically add that for me I guess it
did Oh welcome I forgot that I had in
that package so evidently I have a
package that automatically adds imports
whenever I add these components so
that's pretty cool all right let's just
check really quickly to make sure this
didn't totally mess up the home page and
then we'll go back to this admissions
page okay cool didn't mess it up it
looks all right there I'm okay with that
for now I you know would definitely not
want the same student repeated
over and over again but I'll fix it a
different time now let's go to that
admissions page and actually oh you know
what I didn't yeah I didn't say that
that's what it's wondering why those are
still there okay
so I didn't save it now we've kind of
cut this down and we have this text of
our mission stuff on the home page so
let's I should you know let's open this
twice so that we can see what on the
home page might be good to move over and
perhaps modify for this other page so we
have this mission stuff so probably take
that out but let's see I think we
definitely want this cost in financial
aid section for sure
okay yeah let's do the cost in financial
aid will move we'll take that whole
section just copy it so we'll copy that
over the people were going to admissions
page they're interested in how much it's
gonna cost right so we'll do it we'll
put it down at the bottom so let's go
back over here and copy it there we go
okay so we have my good too far I did I
went too far
all right here's where new stuff ended
so let's start with this div go all the
way up and get this section here we may
have to bring over some classes we'll
see if we have these classes already and
we had some content here that we ended
up taking out looks like it off to check
that out later all right so after this
grid section in admissions we're gonna
put this inverted button oh we need
invert about typography let's see if it
if it
automatically close up let's take out
profile cardinality since we didn't need
it oh it's not gonna do it automatically
nah
No okay I guess so has to do it or I can
just copy it from here innovated button
and I don't remember what the other one
with typography that was it so inverted
button this is the component that we
made which is based on the button
component for material you I actually
material UI has their own kind of like
inverted button I don't know if they
call it that but you'll see what it
looks like in a second so newer versions
of material I have their own since we
already had this made and customized
exactly how we want it I've continued to
use it but if you're using the latest
version you will have that option just
on your regular button component
typography comes built-in in material UI
alright let's see what this looks like
oh yeah we definitely need to bring in
some of the classes so let's do that now
let's just check what classes we have
going on here so it looks like section
inner container section text here Oh
button inverted button alright so let's
see what we can pull over in terms of
classes and let's compare here section
do we have nope
okay so let's go a section inner
container section text here about it
very what yeah all of these down here
so we're copying a lot probably not the
best way to deal with that all right but
first thing is get it get it working
right then we can make it better okay so
let's see if if those styles will fix it
yep and that fix it so here now we have
our cost and financial aid and this is
what I'm talking about with that what I
call an inverted button I don't remember
exactly where I first started that term
but I'm pretty sure I didn't make it up
I think I saw it listed as an inverted
button somewhere so basically you just
have an outline usually I have a hover
effect on these so that when you mouse
in it the background actually we go in
this case it would go like green and
then this text would go to white so I'm
not sure why I did it like this for this
one without the hover okay
all right so there we go we have that
section now so I'm going to check my
time about ten minutes okay so we have
about ten minutes and I think in terms
of bringing stuff from the home page
there's not really much else that I do
want to bring what I think we ought to
do now although is check out the old
site to see what was on there it's I
think it has pretty much the same
content that we saw at the very
beginning before we changed our outer
concedes it the old site very slow I'm
on a really fast connection and it's
still so so slow
I think this is this is really happening
oh you know what I bet it won't even
work because for some reason on campus
you have to put the WWE off campus you
can do it without it it's weird still
really slow though okay
all right wow that that was so slow okay
hey I know her she's really nice let's
see see like part of the reason why I
didn't bring over a lot of the existing
pictures on this site is that they're
really old like she graduated well it's
been a while I mean I think she
graduated before I started working here
so I'll start working here over three
years ago so she's this this photo is
probably at least five years old all
right so here's the only difference
system what we have on this page content
wise we we basically have all this
content right we had these we had these
lists before well we got rid of were
some of these old pictures this is
actually my boss that's fiction my boss
there he's too good guy he's also a good
guy I know him I noticed professor I've
been to his house this is pretty cool
okay it really this page is just a bunch
of links so I I don't know that we
really want to try to copy this page
because I mean do we really do we need a
bunch of links I don't think so
let me know in the in the chat I mean
should we salvage anything from this
page I mean we could certainly add some
of these videos but again these videos
are very old so I might add something in
just as a placeholder and then maybe see
if we can find a new
video I mean I can see maybe for
admissions this video maybe you know
discovery truth fence excuse version
yeah I mean this is pretty much a
general advertising video for the
university
this austria program is a little
specific but it i from what i hear that
it is a big bonus for students didn't
really like it
i'm hesitant to put up a video about the
science programs though because that's
very selective for just one group same
way with theology stuff this these two
videos are more general so i think those
would be okay and honestly i think this
set of videos appears on multiple pages
so i think this was ever meant to be
specific to this page anyway okay so
basically we have apply buttons these
will take people to the same place
anyway there's a campus which we already
have that button so just to show like we
have our apply inquiring visit buttons
which are the most important things
really on the whole site that we want
users to do so we have that we have a
link to our cost calculator we have
links to our majors our institutes
chapel stuff yeah in terms of
information like bringing over
information from here that's the most
important stuff so at this at this point
I don't think I'm gonna bring any of
these other things over unless you know
there's something that basically what
I'm not worried that much about content
like that's not my thing
I'm worried about building this out so
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna fuss about
the content anymore we could grab some
of this text what is this linking to
alright this is a song
we could take some of this text and use
it yeah we could definitely do that all
right let's do that let's make a text
section here and then I think I'd love
to have this quote up here but then I
need something else for there so I'm
gonna leave it leave it alone for right
now and let's add a text section up here
we don't really have anything already
made so instead of copying and pasting
let's just alright let's do as much as
we can in the three minutes that we have
left so what I'm looking to do here is
get this grid so this is already a grid
that has three columns which is what I
want so let's grab this let's grab this
grid and then just kind of take out
everything that's in it and add in some
text okay so in our text there are
sections good stuff yeah all right let's
get rid of this and instead put we're
gonna put this typography element in
there and that's what we're going to put
that's where we're gonna put our text
content in there by default the
typography will just go to a paragraph
tag so that's what it will render to so
that should be fine for now we'll see
how it looks but when we do it in
typography all of our our Styles
the material design type styles should
should work this should just be there so
we're not gonna copy the read more tags
I'm just gonna copy the text for now
what this should give us is on large
screens the loops on large screens
they'll have three columns one on a
small screen they'll stack so it's just
it'll just be one column is the majority
of our target audience is teenagers our
primary target audience is teenagers so
they're most likely going to be using a
mobile device to look at this so we
always want to keep that in mind first
all right whoa all right something's off
about this we definitely don't
maybe we're overriding something just
happen did I forget
alright let's see what these classes are
doing for this grid item I may have to
take that class
okay it's taking out some padding you
know what let's let's take out all of
the custom classes yeah this class name
here I do not want because that that's
probably the lack of padding is probably
not helping and then I don't know what
content containers no one will check
that first we'll see if this did
anything did we get it refresh hmm that
didn't not do anything so let's check on
what content containers - one here with
he
let's check it out in dev tools well
let's check all my timer went off I did
not hear that go off since I already
have this up let's check out the this
div is our grid why is this did not
giving us any margin or padding
all right well I will figure that out at
some other time we can check it out how
it looks on mobile
oh yeah it's still it doesn't look good
this is there's enough there's no space
I'd want some sort of spacing also this
this font size is too small I want that
to be bigger so basically what I would
do here so what I would do up here is
maybe I could possibly use the same
image I don't know we'll see for now
I'll leave that image in there I would
change these obviously to make some
padding make the font size larger switch
this up for something more admissions
related and then the only other thing I
might think about doing is adding in
some videos I think some videos would be
good yeah and then this page I think
would be good to go live it's already
definitely a large improvement over the
other page so in that sense it could
potentially go live and still be better
than the current page but for me to be
really comfortable with it I would make
the changes that I just talked about
first let me check okay let's let's
commit this so we're gonna do a git add
we're at everything we can do it get
status again and make sure so now we
have all this in green this stuff is
ready to be committed so we're gonna run
you're in cm because we have it set up
like a custom little command line
program to help us craft a really good
commit message so we're gonna say we
added in a new feature and let's write a
short so a short imperative tense
description of the chain so we're going
to say add
oh say add profiles to homepage and
content to admissions I'm not gonna do a
long description right now sometimes
that's good if what you change this a
bit more complex probably want to enter
a description of it we do not have
breaking changes so no is the default so
we just hit enter and this is not
effective open issues as far as I know
we do not have an issue for that so I'm
just gonna hit answer it because the
default is no now it's going to run
through our tests our unit tests our
end-to-end tests to be entirely honest
we don't have great test coverage right
now so I don't think anything that we've
done actually would affect anything
that's being tested right now we did
have tests on the home page but it
changed so frequently that the tests
were just kind of getting annoying
because they would fail every time and
we'd have to recreate the test okay
everything worked so now we'll just do a
git push and that will push it to get up
so now everything that I've done here
will be available for you to check out
on the the github page that's linked in
the description now I'm gonna flip back
over to the full screen so that I can
pull over all the chat and just kind of
check it out without the reason I don't
like to show the chat is in case someone
types something inappropriate in the
chat I don't want to be on the stream
right away I could block it and then
hopefully like it won't be visible in
the chat even in the replay I think
that's how it works
okay I'm gonna try my best to keep an
eye on the clock let me move my phone
over actually I got the new pixel three
pixel XL 3 so it just came in kind of
excited about that okay I'm starting way
up at the top I'm going to answer as
much as I possibly can I was just
double-checking to make sure everything
was still going good with
the stream status it does react.js help
over normal jazz while making projects
in express with express limit yeah
Express is really a back-end thing so it
you know reacts I think reacts is easier
for a lot of types of projects than
normal jazz or vanilla J's as some
people say so it doesn't matter whether
you're using express or not I think it's
it does help there are certain very
basic projects that we're probably year
in vanilla jazz I guess it just it just
kind of depends on your project male it
says is it wise to go from few to react
is there anybody here who least try to
taste of both I have not used view so
I'm probably not in a good position to
answer that question all right
lots of happy birthdays thank you thank
you someone asked if I'm a Scorpio yes
I'm a Scorpio I don't really know what
that means in terms of would hold I'm
like I don't really go in for astrology
that much so not I'm not really sure
whether being a Scorpio is a good or a
bad thing
[Music]
Lauren says happy birthday you look 30
years there cool well I that since I'm
33 looking 30 is good I guess day
Stephen says what's up what's up Stephen
Shriram says what's the Google process
of front-end interviews so I'm assuming
the process i've gone through is pretty
standard so what i what you'll do
normally so i got contacted by a
recruiter so my process was slightly
different so i didn't go through the
normal you apply process like i talked
to their cruder we already lined
everything up and and then i I went to a
different I think I went to a different
length to apply
and then I also had someone referring me
within Google so I had to enter their
information as well so slightly
different but the first step is well the
first step for me was talking with the
recruiter I if I had just applied I
don't know if there'd be another first
step where I just talked to somebody but
anyway the real first test was this over
the phone
technical interview so I had to code in
a Google Doc and talk to talk while I
was coding kind of like I do on my show
to the person who was interviewing me it
won't really do any good for me to say
what the question was because every
interviewer will ask different questions
so the best thing is just study for a
lot of stuff and then after that the
next step is to actually go in person to
a Google location where you will have in
my case it's gonna be five interviews
that are all 45 minutes long in person
where each person will ask me a question
so five different interviewers will ask
a question and I will have to most like
then a whiteboard answer write out the
answer to those questions
Lauren says happy birthday from London
cool actually I'll be in London next
week I'm gonna be at the dog fest
conference in Munich but on my way back
from doc fest I'm gonna have really long
layovers in Iceland London and Dublin so
if I know anybody in any of those places
let me know I'll be in Iceland for the
longest period of time so like 22 hours
I'll only be in how a few hours to do
anything in London or Dublin but I'd
like to at least see a little bit of
those places before I fly back sgk asks
for a quick rundown of the project is
about what you're using it react I don't
really have time to give a good run down
right now I'll give the very very
quickest thing it's a react project and
we're using headless WordPress for the
backend we're grabbing the data with
graph QL we're using Apollo with react
to help us out with that and we have a
custom server using Express and node J s
I mean that's what the project is
technologically in terms of what the
project does it is a website for a small
University and yes it probably is
overkill for a website for a small
university but why not do great work
when we can wooden can so Shriram says
what's the goal of this session the
channel has a lot of different videos
but from my videos my live streams the
goal is just for you all to see me doing
my normal work as a developer messing up
trying to recover from those mistakes
and then you know I just want to try to
be as honest as possible about what
what my work is like Molin asks if i'm
using es6 yeah we're using some es6
stuff in here we had a request for
translations into Arabic
I do not know Arabic so I can't
translate but if anybody is interested
in translating my live streams into any
language that would be awesome I'm sure
that Quincy you know who's in charge of
free code camp would welcome some good
translations well cool Stephen says
inverted buttons are kind of like a logo
and a style guide you have the regular
logo and the inverted logo right buttons
really kind of the same way you have
your primary secondary button and then
inverted button Airbnb has it okay so
cool so it is a thing so like I thought
I didn't make the word of it is really a
thing to have inverted buttons okay
Stephen says the problem with updating
is this colleges really need to update
all videos images etc every four years
unless you can link that person to some
kind of alumni group it's out of date
yeah for sure
and that's the the main one of the main
reasons why I decided to start with a
clean slate and not bring over any of
the old videos or images for the most
part was because I knew if we brought
them over people would still just be
okay with it
right but if I brought them over and
they look at a page that's all text then
they'll immediately say where are the
images that and people did that some
people freaked out or like why aren't
there any images or videos well that was
the point the point was we can't just be
lazy about this and be satisfied with
five six year old videos you know
possibly even older and images we need
to get new stuff in here and I knew it
would speed up that process so I still I
still stand by that I think that's
absolutely necessary we're not gonna
start a brand new website with old stuff
Jenya asks about my visual studio theme
I think I have it in the description so
it's the seti theme but check the
description for for details more details
on the theme steve has your lack of
padding is destroyed disturbing said in
my best our theater was that's awesome
and this are so jointly I may be missed
but my question is is react change
there's a lot and lifecycle we'll get
back to the function component so my
question is there any issue with that
for this project in terms of the changes
in the lifecycle methods no I don't
think we have any issues with this
project in case you're not sure what
miss Hart is referring to with some of
the newest versions of react they had to
make changes with the lace out life
cycle methods because there were some
async issues and they're getting ready
to have the suspense API come out so
they
need to fix those issues first so some
of the lifecycle methods they're saying
you shouldn't use them anymore some of
them are changing so just be aware of
that if you have some older react
projects you you may need to change some
lifecycle methods maybe you want to hold
off on updating react until you figure
out exactly how it will affect your
project as you can as if I was using
graph kill in this project I am Carl
asked about the job on a Carl go back
and watch the beginning of the video I
would normally repeat it but I have I
have to end the video really soon so
check out the beginning of the video I
let everybody about the job on and again
if you want to stay more up-to-date on
the job hunt I give them most updates on
my Instagram I also put some updates on
Twitter and I will put a video update a
video summary of my this entire process
on my youtube channel which is linked in
the description after I make my final
decision
umberto says for someone who's
interested in going into web development
as a career what technologies would you
most recommend learning so web
development HTML CSS JavaScript for
Shore start with those alright and that
it should take you a while to get good
with JavaScript if you want to jump into
some sort of JavaScript library or
framework reacts very popular right now
angular is also popular view is a lot a
lot of people like view if you would
like to get into some back-end stuff as
well you can use node.js that would
probably be the easiest thing to get
into if you're already using javascript
on the front end if you have some
specific area you want to go to go into
like let's say you want to be a
wordpress developer then you should
learn PHP you know just kind of check
out what you like and what you want to
do definitely learn how to use api's
graph qo is great but there's not a lot
of people using graph kyo so you'll need
to learn about rest api s as well so
that's just a very quick overview
after clap asked what front-end
languages are there how many JavaScript
is the front-end language so that's the
I know like with web assembly you can
use other stuff like basically in terms
of what's used 99% of the time
JavaScript
who says do you think python is an okay
first language to take up programming as
a hobby oh yeah for sure
I would say as a first language I
recommend either JavaScript or Python if
you're not really interested in the
front end then Python is wonderful if
you do want to do front-end stuff
JavaScript might be a little bit better
because you can't really use Python on
the front end you know but natively in
the browser moose says I really want to
do something in programming but I don't
have any time at all because it just
started in medical school this year
yeah that's gonna be tough my advice to
you would be maybe try to do just a
little bit every day if you can even do
a half an hour every day at least it
would keep you keep your mind on it you
know maybe start out with some free code
camp stuff just just do just work on
free code camps curriculum half hour
every day even if it's 15 minutes every
day it's still better than nothing
Jesse you're amazing hi from your
Russian fans hey how's it going I was so
close to being able to come to Russia
for a conference I was almost picked I
talked to the organizers did like an
interview thing and so I was a little
bit bummed I was going to be coming I
was hoping I'd be in Russia at the end
of November but it's not gonna happen
now
maybe maybe someday I'll apply for the
conference next year you guys say I'm
new to react and I would like to know
what is the proper way of navigating
through different layouts I'm not I'm
not exactly sure what you mean by
navigating through different layouts so
maybe you know what I want to really
have time to answer that so if you can
message me on Twitter or put a comment
to this video maybe I can answer answer
that question okay it looks like there
are some answers in in the chatter
already so thank you for that Christian
says what's best Python or JavaScript I
think I just answered that before I'm
not I'm not
say one language is better than the
other but it just depends on when you're
trying to use them for it
Mario says are you moving to angular
I've no I'm not moving angular for most
of my job offers I'll still be working
with react obviously for the Google one
probably not but for all the other ones
it's it's react if some of the offers
I'd actually get to keep doing my stream
with my work so that's that's a big plus
oh alright steven has a call and that's
your that's your interview awesome yeah
for sure let me know on Twitter what
happens Moussa says thank you you're
welcome
okay and I have a meeting in four
minutes so I'm gonna wrap up the stream
sorry at least the question answer was
so rushed and quick hopefully I'll be
able to do another stream but I I might
be traveling hopefully I'll be traveling
out to Google headquarters sometime
later in the week and then next week I
will be in Europe a couple of days in
Germany a day in Iceland half a day at
Dublin half a day in London so if you're
in any of those places let me know I'd
be really interested in like getting
some coffee together or hanging out or
something
like so if you want to get in touch with
me my Instagram info and my Twitter info
are in the description of this video if
you want to see more of my videos check
out all the playlists here on free code
camp for live coding with Jesse or you
can check out my youtube video it's
linked in the description so thank you
all so much for watching and for hanging
out with me in a lot chat I'll see you
next time